saludos en esta ocasión les voy a
mostrar algo muy extraño que la primera
vez que lo vi me molestó un poco así que
quizás ustedes tengan una reacción
similar y espero que lo superen al
terminar este vídeo esta cosa loca es
que digamos que tenemos esta pelota que
rebota y si va en línea recta puede
tener un momento angular lo digo de
nuevo una pelota que viaja en línea
recta puede tener momento angular y la
primera vez que vi esto dije que como es
posible no hay manera de que esta pelota
tenga momento angular se está moviendo
en línea recta ni siquiera está rotando
acaso las cosas no deben de tener cierta
rotación para tener momento angular y
resulta que no pero la respuesta
apropiada es un poco extraña y antes de
explicarles el porqué vamos a ver esto
podría ser que esto no tenga un momento
angular y antes de que se confunda mucho
permítanme explicarles que la respuesta
apropiada a alguien que pregunta esta
pelota tiene momento angular
la respuesta es un momento angular sobre
que el eje debemos que especificar el
eje el eje es el punto sobre el cual
vamos a considerar la rotación y si
pregunto quién es esta pelota momento
angular si la pelota se mueve en línea
recta tendrá un momento angular en
relación con este eje esa es una
pregunta apropiada pero si preguntamos
esta pelota tiene momento angular sin
especificar el eje pues esta pregunta no
tendrá sentido así que vamos a
analizarlo porque tendría un momento
angular esta pelota sin importar
cualquier eje esta es la parte que
confunde no está rotando como es posible
que si se está moviendo en línea recta
tenga un momento angular sabemos que
tiene momento regular ya que se está
moviendo por lo que tiene masa y
velocidad entonces tiene momento pero no
está rotando como es posible que tenga
un momento angular 1er
vamos a explicar conceptualmente porque
esto tiene sentido imaginemos que
tenemos esta barra que estamos
observando por arriba esta barra está
sujeta a un eje y puede rotar e
imaginemos que todo esto está encima de
una mesa y lo estamos observando todo
desde arriba imaginamos que lanzamos
esta pelota que se está moviendo en una
línea recta golpea al borde de esta
barra y qué es lo que va a hacer esta
barra pues ya sabemos que va a ser va a
rotar sobre su eje y la pregunta es esta
barra inicialmente no tenía momento
angular ya que se encontraba aquí en
reposo y después tuvo un momento angular
cuando fue golpeada por la pelota ya que
los objetos que rotan el círculo tiene
el momento angular de donde obtuvo esta
barra su momento angular pues lo único
con lo que interactúa esta barra fue
esta pelota por lo que esta pelota al
llegar debió de transferirle cierto
momento angular ya que de otra forma
como es posible que la barra comenzará a
tener momento
es decir si tenemos en mente la
conservación del momento este momento
angular tuvo que venir de alguna parte
no salió así de la nada así que el único
lugar de donde pudo obtener ese momento
angular fue de la pelota ya que es la
única otra cosa que tenemos en este
problema por lo tanto la pelota tuvo que
llegar con su propio momento angular aún
cuando se encontraba viajando en línea
recta lo cual es extraño pero es lo que
sucede así es la física y también
explica el por qué esto depende de donde
se encuentre el eje si tomamos esta
barra y la movemos hasta acá
de manera que el eje se encuentre en
este punto ahora imaginen que la pelota
golpea a la barra en el eje si la golpea
aquí no va a hacer que la barra rote ya
que la va a golpear en el eje por lo que
la ubicación del eje va a determinar el
momento angular que un objeto tiene
cuando está viajando en línea recta si
la pelota golpea a la barra en el eje no
le va a transferir momento angular pero
si golpea a la barra
lejos del eje entonces le puede
transferir bastante cantidad de momento
angular ya que la barra va a rotar mucho
tendremos que se aplica una mayor
cantidad de torque porque la fuerza se
aplica en un lugar que está bastante
alejado del eje y que sea ustedes no
están tan impresionados con esto quizás
esto les suene a pura brujería física
cómo podemos calcular o definir esto
exactamente como definimos el hecho de
que esta bola tiene momento angular
vamos a definir esto con exactitud
digamos que esta pelota tiene una
rapidez o velocidad de esta pelota tiene
una masa m y la distancia del eje a la
pelota vamos a dibujarla desde el eje
hasta la bola y esto le vamos a llamar r
minúscula y ahora sí podemos definir con
precisión lo que significa el momento
angular de una masa puntual el momento
angular de una masa puntual que lo
representamos con la letra l mayúscula
hacer m la masa de la bola o la masa del
objeto que tiene el momento angular m
multiplicado por la rapidez de la bola
que es ve y nos comienza a parecer
bastante familiar ya que m por b es
momento hasta aquí tendríamos el momento
regular pero queremos el momento angular
y esto lo tenemos multiplicando por r&r
se define como la distancia desde el eje
hasta donde se encuentra el objeto esta
es la distancia r pero aún no hemos
terminado nos falta un término más y es
el seno del ángulo entre los vectores
velocidad y r por lo que aquí ponemos el
seno de este ángulo de acá entre los
vectores velocidad y r y aquí esto
podría parecer algo descuidado si hay
personas que están poniendo atención me
pueden decir que técnicamente este
vector r va desde el eje hasta la masa
por lo que técnicamente este no es el
ángulo entre b y r tendríamos que m
r comienza desde acá y entonces si
calcular el ángulo entre estos dos
sectores pero como estamos calculando el
seno el seno de los ángulos
suplementarios siempre va a ser el mismo
así que si tenemos el seno de estos
ángulos pues cualquiera que tomemos como
son ángulos suplementarios nos va a dar
el mismo resultado con el celo así que
no hay ningún problema de que tomemos
algunos de estos ángulos de aquí de
cualquier manera obtendremos la
respuesta correcta pero esto suena
complicado es decir m por b por ere por
seno de teta no quiere hacer todos estos
cálculos y no tienen que hacer tantos
cálculos hay un truco si consideramos lo
que significa r por seno de teta
visualmente que es lo que representa
esto aquí esta es toda la cantidad r
esto es theta e imaginamos que
completamos un triángulo usando r y este
ángulo que va de aquí
y de aquí a acá así que tenemos este
triángulo este ere por el seno de teta
es este lado de acá este lado de aquí es
el lado opuesto si esto nos confunde
recuerden que el seno de teta es igual
al lado opuesto entre la hipotenusa y el
lado opuesto a este ángulo es r
mayúscula y la hipotenusa es esta r
minúscula y si multiplicó ambos lados
por r minúscula voy a tener
r por seno de teta y esta teta de aquí
es este ángulo de acá y r por seno de
teta es igual a esta r mayúscula de acá
que es la distancia de la aproximación
más cercana por lo que cuando esta
pelota llega hasta este punto de acá
viajando en esta dirección a una rapidez
b estará a una distancia r del eje por
lo que lo único que tenemos que hacer
para encontrar el momento angular de un
objeto que es una masa puntual aún
cuando esta masa puntual viaje en línea
recta es tomar la masa borde y si no
quieren meterse
con senos de ángulos pues esto lo vamos
a multiplicar por r mayúscula que es la
distancia de mayor acercamiento con el
eje esto es lo que significa esta r
mayúscula la distancia a la aproximación
más cercana al eje y justamente es esta
distancia entre este eje y el punto en
donde la pelota va a estar más cercana
al eje y esta r por seno de teta siempre
va a ser igual a esto así que para
facilitarnos la vida imaginen que cuando
esta pelota se está acercando vemos cuál
es el punto en donde ésta va a estar más
cercano al eje que es este y luego vemos
qué tan lejos está este punto del eje y
así obtendremos esta r mayúscula y
podremos multiplicar m por b por r que
nos va a dar el momento angular de una
masa puntual la cantidad total de
momento angular que este objeto puede
transferir a otro objeto es la cantidad
de momento angular que la barra puede
obtener al ser golpeada por la pelota
veamos un ejemplo un ejemplo clásico de
una pelota que golpea a una barra y a
los profesores de física les encanta
esto así que vamos a prepararnos para
resolver esto digamos que tenemos una
barra que es golpeada por una pelota la
pelota viene por acá y va a golpear a la
barra y vamos a poner algunas cantidades
en este problema para que así podamos
resolverlo la bola tiene una masa de 5
kilogramos tiene una velocidad de 8
metros por segundo
golpea al extremo de la barra y la barra
tiene una masa de 10 kilogramos y una
longitud de 4 metros y vamos a suponer
que esta barra tiene una densidad
uniforme por lo que la masa en esta
barra va a estar distribuida
uniformemente en toda ella y va a rotar
en el otro extremo así que cuando la
bola golpea a la barra la barra va a
comenzar a rotar alrededor de su eje
vamos a suponer que cuando esta pelota
golpea a la barra la pelota se para se
detiene así que la pelota se para y la
barra comienza a rotar
de manera que va a tener todo el momento
angular que tenía la pelota y esto nos
va a facilitar los cálculos y más
adelante veremos qué es lo que sucede
cuando esto no ocurre tampoco es tan
difícil pero digamos que en este ejemplo
la pelota se para cuando golpea a la
barra como resolvemos este problema pues
vamos a tratar de usar la conservación
del momento angular digamos que aunque
aquí tenemos un eje que está ejerciendo
una fuerza la fuerza que este eje va a
ejercer en nuestro sistema va a
ocasionar cero torque debido al valor de
r el torque es igual a r por efe por
seno de teta y en este caso la erre es
cero ya que es la distancia del eje a la
fuerza quiere decir que no va a haber
torque ejercido por este eje y si no hay
un torque ejercido externamente no va a
haber un momento angular en el sistema
así que este sistema de la barra y la
pelota no va a tener un torque externo
lo que quiere decir que el momento
angular va a permanecer igual
es un problema clásico de conservación
del momento l inicial o el momento
angular inicial tiene que ser igual al
momento angular final así que para todo
nuestro sistema cuál será el momento
angular inicial pues está en esta masa y
cuál es este momento angular inicial
recuerden que esto es m por b por r
mayúscula y r mayúscula es la distancia
a la aproximación más cercana así que
podemos usar esta distancia de los
cuatro metros como r podemos considerar
esto la hipotenusa r minúscula por el
seno del ángulo pero es más difícil de
hacer y no hay necesidad de hacerlo lo
podemos encontrar como m br y esto es
igual al momento angular final recuerden
que esta pelota se detiene se para
cuando golpea a la barra de manera que
solamente la barra es la que tiene el
momento angular después del impacto así
que solo tenemos que preocuparnos por el
momento angular de la barra y para
encontrar el momento angular de un
objeto rígido tendremos que usar
y esto nos va a permitir encontrar cuál
es la velocidad angular final de esta
barra después de la colisión y es lo que
queremos encontrar cuál es la velocidad
angular final de la barra después de la
colisión y lo podemos calcular tenemos
la masa de la pelota conocemos la
rapidez inicial de esta pelota y
conocemos esta distancia r mayúscula la
distancia a la aproximación más cercana
que es de 4 metros cuál será el momento
de inercia aquí vamos a hacer un poco de
espacio para escribir le hacemos esto a
un lado y escribimos el momento de
inercia para una barra o un objeto
extendido de material rígido y que está
rotando en uno de sus extremos es de un
tercio por m por l al cuadrado un tercio
por la masa de la barra por la longitud
de la barra al cuadrado y ésta eleva a
sido igual a esta r de acá son la misma
longitud ya que el punto de la
aproximación más cercana coincide con la
longitud de la barra ya que la pelota la
golpea en el extremo y esto lo
multiplicamos por omega
vamos a despejar a un mega vamos a poner
esto por aquí abajo lado mega final de
la barra va a ser igual a la masa de la
bola por la rapidez inicial de esta bola
multiplicada por la línea de mayor
aproximación y lo voy a dividir entre un
tercio de la masa de la barra por la
longitud de la barra la cual vamos a
llamar r ya que es la misma cantidad la
longitud de la barra al cuadrado canceló
una de estas erres y sustituyó los
valores para obtener la cantidad que
quiero la velocidad angular de esta
barra va a ser igual a 5 kilogramos que
es la masa de la pelota por 8 metros por
segundo que es la rapidez inicial de
esta pelota y lo dividimos entre un
tercio de la masa de la barra que es de
10 kilogramos multiplicado por la
longitud de la barra que es esta
distancia de mayor aproximación 4 metros
y si calculamos todo esto nos va a dar 3
radiales por segundo
esta es la cantidad de velocidad angular
o de rapidez angular que va a tener esta
barra después de la colisión con la
pelota y se haya transferido el momento
angular de la pelota por completo a la
barra dándole momento angular a la barra
lo que va a ocasionar que ésta comience
a rotar y lo va a ser a tres radiales
por segundo y que haríamos diferentes y
en lugar de que la pelota se detuviera
está rebotar y rebota con una rapidez de
dos metros por segundo bueno en este
caso el momento angular final no sería
solamente el momento angular de la barra
tendremos que incluir el momento angular
de la pelota pero aquí hay una parte
curiosa si la pelota venía en esta
dirección inicialmente lo que significa
que tendría un momento angular en esta
dirección inicialmente si la pelota
regresa en sentido contrario ahora
tendrá un momento angular en esta otra
dirección por lo que deberemos tener un
signo negativo aquí cuando incluyamos
ese término en el lado derecho de ésta
hay dos formas en las que podemos
incluir lo podemos poner aquí uno más y
ponemos la masa de la pelota
multiplicada por este menos dos metros
por segundo
multiplicado por los mismos cuatro
metros como la línea de la mayor
aproximación o la aproximación más
cercana podemos poner el menos aquí con
el más acá o podemos poner el menos aquí
y el más acá podemos hacerlo de
cualquier manera pero este término de
acá para el momento final de la pelota
va a tener que tener este signo negativo
que es diferente al signo que tenía el
momento angular inicial de la pelota en
resumen una pelota puede tener un
momento angular aún cuando se esté
moviendo en línea recta y podemos
determinar el momento angular de esta
pelota usando m por b por r por seno de
teta donde la r minúscula es la
distancia del eje al objeto al lugar
donde se encuentra la pelota y teatre es
el ángulo entre r
pero si no quieren usar rs no detectan
podemos usar m por b por r mayúscula
donde la r mayúscula representa la
distancia en donde la pelota va a estar
más cercana al eje conforme la pelota
viaja en línea recta